if it takes me get naked for you to care
about animals then that is what I'm
after Alicia Silverstone bearing it all
yet again for a cause that's near and
dear I've been working with Peta for 22
23 years and done many many different
campaigns yeah the actress left little
to the imagination in past collabs well
it was the first time I had ever ever
been in any way shape or form naked in
any kind of film and Alicia's ready to
continue spreading the word by stripping
down if it takes me get naked for you to
care about animals then that is what I'm
after it's the most important thing to
me in my life so I would love to be able
to educate the entire world about how
every creature is as important as the
next and these campaigns are a big deal
for Alicia who's never gone nude for
Hollywood uh as if I never ever get
naked in TV in film nothing never
nope but I've done it for PETA because
that's how much it matters to me and we
also want a healthier life
so I'd rather go naked than wear animals
and we know Alicia's all about promoting
body positivity I'm not gonna do any
work I'm just gonna continue to be
natural and we'll see maybe I'll be an
example of what actually aging healthily
looks like right and as she explained to
E.T thanks to tick tock each of them are
just fun silly things she's found
another way to get the attention of her
fans my son had been talking about
when I kept saying no no no no and
finally I gave in and thought it would
be really fun and also a way to get
people over to my classes that I really
care about
[Music]
yep that's Alicia's son bear last year
helping Mom recreate some iconic
clueless moments shares a very happy
girl
get in here what's up Daddy what the
hell is that a dress says who Calvin
Klein it looks like underwear but Stacey
Dash upped the ante in 2022 that was a
stop sign I totally paused recruiting
Alicia for a class reunion for Sharon
Dion
would you call me selfish no not your
face would you call me selfish no not
your face
[Music]